le Val de Loire au rythme dure rugby en
attendant la Coupe du Monde et la venue
de l'équipe d'Irlande à Tours en
septembre prochain d'autres rendez-vous
se profil à l'horizon ça débute dès
samedi avec une rencontre féminine de
haut niveau on en parle avec le patron
du rugby chez nous bonsoir Rodolphe
Esteve bon vous êtes président de la
ligue du Centre Val de Loire de rugby
alors ce match de rugby donc opposera
l'équipe de France féminine des moins de
20 ans à celle d'Angleterre c'est samedi
à 18h au stade de la Vallée du Cher on
découvre l'affiche et ce qu'on appelle
un test match et à travers cet événement
c'est le rugby féminin qui est mise à
l'honneur c'est une volonté de la
Fédération de la Ligue de mettre les
femmes à l'honneur dans ce sport qui est
le rugby
alors une volonté de la Fédération oui
forcément mais le développement du rugby
féminin depuis quelques années il est il
est réel et on a la chance sur la Ligue
centre d'avoir un collectif notamment
sur l'agglomération tourangelle je
jouais les tours qui a fait des grandes
performances et la volonté qu'on avait
d'accueillir un match international
depuis qu'on est aux commandes depuis
deux ans
on avait plutôt essayé d'avoir un match
féminin parce que justement cet élan
féminin nous intéresse beaucoup c'est là
que se trouve finalement la progression
des effectifs dans les clubs il y a une
belle marge au niveau du rugby féminin
et bien après le covid nous a pas trop
handicapé en fait on a réussi à garder
les clubs ouverts c'est réadapté mettre
en place des situations de jeu pour les
enfants qu'on permis de les accueillir
et du coup on est en augmentation depuis
cette triste période et on vient de
passer la barre symbolique pour nous de
10 licenciés sur la région Centre 10
licenciés dont 10% de femmes donc qui
jouent au rugby qui seront devant
France-Angleterre ce samedi ce qui a la
même rivalité que chez les hommes dans
ce genre de match entre la France et
l'Angleterre forcément c'est une culture
les crunchs donc j'espère en tout cas
que nos jeunes représentants de
françaises ont envie de d'en découdre
ils ont gagné au match aller j'espère
qu'ils vont faire la même chose remettre
ce retour cette semaine ouais 35 17 au
match Chanel partent clairement favorite
pour ce match retour
oui on va dire oui et puis on a la
chance de voir quelques régionales de
l'étape en tout cas au moins une qui
devrait jouer samedi une orléanaise
Enzo Jean je crois alors parce que c'est
ça les U20 c'est un peu l'antichambre du
15 de France et notamment vous le dites
il y a une jeune Jocondienne qui a fait
ses marques ici chez nous qui alors qui
ne jouera pas là pour les U20 mais qui a
été sélectionné pour l'équipe de France
du 15 c'est ça exactement elle était au
début avec le collectif
U20 et avec les performances elle est
dans l'équipe de France jouera elle
dimanche à Vannes contre l'Écosse avec
la grande équipe Elisa rifonaute c'est
cela on va donc découvrir de nombreux
talents lors de ce match samedi il y a
du beau jeu on l'a vu sur les extraits
ça joue vite ça joue technique et rapide
c'est tout le charme du sport collectif
féminin je crois que c'est un peu
pareil avec le football avec le handball
le basket on voit des choses différentes
il y a beaucoup moins enfin il y a de
l'engagement je veux pas dire qu'il y a
pas d'engagement mais c'est plus
technique c'est plus rapide enfin il y a
ça mode beaucoup de fraîcheur à toutes
ces disciplines collectives le rugby
féminin on l'a dit c'est un millier de
licences entre Val de Loire est-ce que
vous espérez un effet coupe du monde en
septembre pour attirer de nouveaux
licenciés au sein de la fédération et
nos prédécesseurs en 2007 avaient eu une
augmentation de licence hauteur de 25
30% donc on estime que cette vraie à peu
près avoir les mêmes incidences là
oui on attend et on forme des éducateurs
en attendant la vraie difficulté sera
d'avoir des installations sportives à la
hauteur mais au moins surtout il y aura
la chambreerie la chambre aurait qui
sera donc inaugurée en juillet c'est là
que s'entraînera l'équipe d'Irlande
notamment qui viendra en septembre pour
la Coupe du Monde l'idée c'est de créer
une espèce de ferveur autour de cette
équipe d'Irlande alors une volonté alors
là qui dépasse largement la Ligue de
tour c'est vraiment très très impliqué
sur l'accueil des Irlandais le
conseiller régional a fait de gros
efforts il y a une association qui s'est
montée les clubs touranjo sont derrière
enfin c'est une chance énorme de
d'accueillir cette sélection qui est
quand même la Première Guerre mondiale
pour l'instant donc voilà on espère
faire la finale contre eux puis qu'il a
perdent mon français
Dupont lève la coupe on va acheter un
coup d'oeil au calendrier rugbytique en
centre Val de Loire notamment à Tours
alors donc on a parlé de ce match samedi
et puis il y a le tournoi Howard Hinton
tournoi de rugby à 7 qu'est-ce que c'est
exactement
moi qui a plus de 25 ans d'âge
maintenant qui a été qui a été mis en
place pour rendre hommage un joueur de
l'US tour qui est décédé trop tôt et ses
copains de l'époque des silures rendre
hommage et de faire un tournoi à 7 donc
j'avais commencé petite choisir en nous
et maintenant c'est vraiment un
événement dimension internationale qui
est reconnu sur l'ensemble au moins du 7
français autre grand rendez-vous
rapidement la Coupe du monde scolaire en
septembre
rugby rugby heritage Cup pardon pour le
l'accent à pont-levoi c'est ça c'est une
première c'est ça donc je qualifierais
ça plutôt d'un tournoi international
Coupe du Monde un tournoi international
scolaire oui sur dans le Loir-et-Cher
bon une idée fantastique de leur
directeur François roche Bayard qui a
décidé d'accueillir des écoles venant de
l'ensemble de la planète et des équipes
qualifiées pour la grande coupe du monde
merci beaucoup Rodolphe stp président de
la ligue centre-valoire est devenu ce
soir sur notre plateau vous voulez
ajouter un dernier mot rapidement un
dernier mot pour samedi je veux
remercier sincèrement le comité des
portals de rugby 37 et son président
Francis dirison ainsi que les
associations
Hinton et j'iat sont associations tout
Ranger qui donne un gros gros coup de
main dans lesquels je serai pas possible
d'accueillir samedi au moins 5000
spectateurs merci beaucoup ouais c'est
vrai que c'est une énorme jauge merci
beaucoup